This is a quiz to get you started with Python.
We define a function that’s called sine
underscore cosine and this function should
create arrays called X sine underscore X,
cosine underscore X and fill these arrays with
values that allow us to eventually plot the
sine and the cosine curve from X equals zero
to X equals two pi, exactly two pi.
Your task is to fill in the code in this loop that
iterates over fifty points. Make sure that X
ranges from zero to two pi exactly. Sine X is the
corresponding sine value,
cosine X is the corresponding cosine
value and then the matplotlib
package will take care of plotting the curves.